this is Tommy Lasorda Gary I want to ask
you how do you keep your people
motivated Tommy thanks for the great
question uh you know obviously being one
of the great managers of all time this
answer is going to come very easy to you
and very natural I think you'll get it I
think I spend a lot of time thinking
about motivation and I think the key for
me is I try to motivate in a couple ways
number one by example I think my actions
will always speak louder than my words
so how I carry myself how I interact
everybody how I live myself let me live
my life as a man I think really matters
as a and as an executive as a person I
think everyone's always watching but I
also think I equally try to reverse them
in your every single individual person
right they're just all different they
all have different kpi's different
objectives they're in different parts of
their lives some are married some just
had kids some are trying to make more
money some don't want to have four
roommates in Brooklyn like so they're
grinding so like everybody's got a
different thing and I think what's
important for me to motivate is to do a
great job listening to what makes them
tick both when I have the few moments
with them in person like Alex get over
here for a second so like let's do a
real life example on the askgaryvee show
Alex what motivates you what are you
what are you excited about like what
about yeah like what yeah like what
motivates you in life I just like doing
cool all right like that's it like
pretty much I want to like be successful
and just do cool basically why I'm here
so you know cool man all right get out
of here so you know Alex is easy he just
wants to do cool that's easy we do tons
of cool please check he's good he's
motivated and you go on and on on and
you try to figure out was that like he
was scared that he was on camera is that
the real answer like are they gonna
really tell me the truth doing they
never tell me the truth usually upfront
few and far between and so it's a
constant you know behavioral HR driven
reverse engineering what they care about
like India and I had a pretty intense
conversation about her future ambitions
like what yeah remember you wanted to be
the head of social media for museums and
things like I took that very seriously
like I know these things about my peeps
is long before india was on the inner
circle of the this team like like
like I remembered it better than you did
seriously so like I mean so I take an
enormous flick you don't get to be a
great all-time leader without being a
great all-time leader so there's a lot
of work that gets put into being good at
what I do and I'm very very up to the
challenge and so it's predicated on an
enormous amount of listening which is
why I'm such a paradox because boy do I
love to talk but the amount of listening
that I'm actually doing always surprises
people when they start going a couple of
layers deeper so the answer to your
question is I motivate Tommy by figuring
out what every single person is ticked
and wired like and what makes them roll
and I also recognize that that changes
every single day and they have four to
seven twelve milestone things that
happen in their lives which will change
the trajectory of their ambitions wants
hopes and dreams and I need to be
prepared for every single one of those
for all of them forever
you